throw to have here on the Rich Eisen
show from Crimson Tide Fame with Alabama
being number one as well everything's
working for Mark Ingram how are you mark
how are you I am I'm better for chatting
with you where did this seven-game win
streak come from mark man it came from
within you know we were sitting there
over - and we knew we had to go to
Carolina and nobody's gonna have to
leave Carolina and go to London for a
big game out there so we knew on that
road trip you know it was gonna tell us
a lot about our church our team on that
road trip so you know you can sit there
and you can followed and you know feel
sorry for yourself or you can you know
put your foot and ground keep grinding
it and I turn this thing around you know
that's what we did it man we went to
Carolina had a had a tough road winning
division over there then we went to
London and uh you know was able to beat
Miami so then we had the bye week and we
just been grinding ever since fair so we
just we just been grinded man we wanted
to turn it around so can you take me in
the running back room when Adrian was
there when Peterson was there I was part
of the week one where everybody thought
well here comes Peterson in his old
house and he's death staring down the
coach and it was awkward for everybody
just watching what was it like for you
and Alvin Kamara and Adrian Peterson in
that room mark we didn't know what was
gonna happen you know we was just uh all
trying to go with the flow all trying
just to be ready you know we've been
working on all season all training camp
and we were ready to you know help our
team win and you know we wanted to all
be effective we all wanted to be
efficient and we didn't know how it was
gonna play out as far as roles or plays
or anything like that but we were always
just hoping for the best and going in
there with a you know but when it added
to and so when Peterson left did that
he'll obviously just from outside it
made it seem like it helped delineate
your roles a little better what about
from your perspective of quarters I mean
you know we had three guys that we were
trying to get involved in the game plan
and um you know he wanted the ball alive
I want the ball Ivan wants the ball and
so we were just kind of just going with
the flow man and it was what it was and
we were trying to figure it out you know
and when they made that movie was just
like okay it's time for me Alvin to step
it up and improve that uh you know you
know we could be carry this team and we
could be effective we could be explosive
we could be eliminated for this team
help us win games and that's how we took
it that's how we've been working and we
just want to be the best so we push each
other every day man
well so what are your roles cuz I'm sure
you you are somebody who takes pride in
being able to pass block and catch out
of the backfield and I'm sure Kumar is
somebody who prides himself and running
in between the tackles and getting tough
yards in the red zone so walk me through
marking room what is the role that you
think there are play the role is
whatever it is that week you know we're
both very versatile we could run we can
run routes out of the backfield catch
the ball well out of the backfield in
the screen game catch the ball and a
link plays in space we could run the
ball inside run the ball outside with
bulk very versatile so you can plug us
in anywhere then with his expand the
role being able to run from the slide
now wide though you know the full route
tree that just you know makes it more of
a problem so we both take pride in being
versatile but our complete bags that
could pass pro do everything but
whatever our role is for that week
whatever the game plan is for that week
that's what we gonna thrive in and
that's what we're gonna accept and we're
gonna try to do whatever we can to help
our team win and make play so that's
just that's the bottom line man we're
ready for whatever the role may be each
week well I guess it's contagious
because now Drew Brees is running them
in we noticed that yesterday I mean
you're gonna throw wet mark you're gonna
you're gonna have something we're gonna
throw one in yeah I've been waiting you
know we do lose you know we'd be tossing
around seven or seven drops on there you
know if the running back doesn't get a
ball on a go ride or something I'll toss
it out there you know akp tossing it out
there so we be trying to show off our
heart so we can get a little past play
in there but when it happens it happens
we don't want to take too many passes
number nine cuz he's a he's going with
the ball in his head throwing the ball
well what is it like being in the huddle
with him mark walked me through him man
this dude is amazing just to be able to
come in as a rookie and uh you know be
able to learn from him see his work
ethic and just being in the huddle
Heavy's always have control of the
hallways in command
always positive always confident always
high-energy you never see you never see
him fazed by anything he's always ready
for the next play no matter what
happened the letter what may have
happened if he just got you know blew up
hit in the face he's my guys next play
let's play let's play he'll say to play
it we'll be right back there his
demeanor and huddle is why he is who he
is that's why he the first bow how a
family that's why he's broken all these
records that's why he's won all these
games it just says to me then how he
approaches everything what about your
relationship Mark Ingram with your alpha
male of a head coach sometimes it seems
like the - you guys are butting heads be
very honest from where you're watching
and if ever you unfortunately put the
ball on the turf you hear about it and
sometimes you might actually be watching
from the sidelines yeah what do you got
the ability man you got to take care of
football you know that's the bottom line
at this game of football stuff happens
but you know the main main objective is
to you know take care of their football
man score with the football and don't
give it to other team you know I want to
win I want to be great he must where he
wants to you know he's a super boats
head coach and he wants to get back
there I mean he demands perfection he
demands everybody's best man you know we
hold him to that same standard man we
know he's going you know he's going to
give us our best he's going to give us
his best game plan he's going to give us
his best man so he demands the same
thing from us that's a standard in his
building everybody wants to be great
everyone wants to be elite and so we
hold each other to that standard so we
know when he's on me I'll take it to
heart I know that you know we try to win
this game and that's the bottom line man
so we're all competitive we all want to
be great we all want to win so when it
comes to the field and things that
happened on the field it's nothing
personal it's just the heat of the
moment it's the environment it's the
nature of our game and you know tempers
flare and guys are competitive guys want
to win so it's nothing personal it's all
business we just want to win that's no
more goal is to win I guess your your
you got to have thick skin when you play
for Nick Saban already right yeah
because he's gonna be at you so you know
and I grew up my father you know he take
it easy on me at all
I've always been haven't been afraid of
criticism constructive criticism you
know so I take coaching and you got to
you have to learn you have to be a
coastal player that's how you learn is
how you get better you don't know
everything you keep learning every day
so you got to be coachable
well you got you came into the league
two years after the Saints won at all
okay and you know what it's like to win
a national championship at the
collegiate level mark what about this
aren't set up with this team the feeling
that might be around in that locker room
around the practice field makes you
think that perhaps something specials
brewing with the New Orleans Saints 27
you could you can feel it managers
energy that we bring to the building
every day to the feedings to the
walkthrough to the practice to the
periods and practice to our tempo
everything you know how guys care for
each other we're spending time together
in the building out the building guys
care for each other guys are planning
for one another
everybody you know nobody's trying to be
super everybody's trying to be super fun
but everybody has to focus on their job
do their job to the best of their
ability and that's what we're doing and
we're playing complimentary football or
bad stuff happens or you know
everything's not gonna go your way in
this game of football or and you know
something happens there's not ideal you
can't be can't panic you know you have
to be able to put your foot down to
fight through adversity and I think
we've been doing a good job good job of
that and uh you know not living on 72
win over Washington company here we have
to get it done a win
so we're taking it one day at a time
we're meeting at a time of practice and
it's a little rough at a time now
looking ahead we're trying to get better
each day each opportunity that presents
itself we're trying to improve well
before I let you go in terms of being
fearless I did notice a couple of times
when you scored in western New York in
Buffalo mark you jumped into the stands
what what compelled you to do something
like that to spike if I was just looking
today where are you off do it there's
also a little kid were in the number 22
Jersey like a pitcher for handle right
and so I jumped in there and I was
trying to like get a picture with a kid
but somebody was pulling me then the
toss the beer
it was boom the second one the second
touchdown why jumped in there what it
better say said that's how a little bit
more cordial to that first one it was a
little heck it'd shows up to a Bills
game wearing a Mark Ingram Saints gamer
got to have a moment with you and that
dream moment for that kid gets
interrupted by a splashing beer that
actually happened
listen this happens man this is you
can't make this up and this is real I
hate flies you can't make this up man
you know I see a kid right here front
row the front of all these bill says he
has a Mark Ingram jersey on right in
front of me right I'm like I'm
definitely taking a picture with this
kid like this is awesome and uh so I
jumped in there and I'm trying to get
you see me I'm trying to I put my arm
around it you see some people pulling me
from this way are they try to pull me in
just kind of let me kind of weather the
storm that uh-oh here comes the beer and
then my teammates is uh pulling me down
and I'm running over there my helmet
smells like beer for the first half we
ended up having a good game those all
for it okay
well enjoy I assume you'll be an
interested observer on Miami and the
Dolphins Panthers game tonight mark oh
yeah I'll be tuned into that was for
sure okay
thanks for joining in I would love to
have you back on later on in the season
is they Alabama starts playing some more
important games as well get your give me
a shout glad you guys had me I
appreciate it I mean I follow you on
twitter at Mark Ingram 22 everybody
should do that too thanks for calling in
mark about to follow you back rich oh
wait a minute you don't already mark I
look forward to seeing that Mark Ingram
22 follows you I look forward to seeing
that you take care all right thank you
take care you got that's marking the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience